et pourquoi pas pourquoi pas être
candidat je ce qui m'a convaincu c'est
le traitement a achevé de convaincre
c'est le traitement actuel de la
pandémie par l'état c'est ce grand
jacques a dit ce grand emmanuel a dit un
jour ont porté masquer un jour ne
portent pas et de voir que en toile de
fond l'appauvrissement du peuple se
poursuit les libertés individuelles
recul et les divisions soit disant
identitaire s'aggrave
c'est le spectre de la guerre civile
tout cela à mon avis mène à
l'effondrement de la vème république
pour les mêmes raisons pour la quatrième
le régime des partis mais je me demande
si cette fois ci ce n'est pas la
république toute entière qui va y passer
[Musique]
ce sont d'abord des principes il est
possible que le clivage droite gauche et
disparus mais cette disparition ne fait
que révéler un clivage est essentielle
et qui a peut-être de tout temps existé
c'est celui de la compétition entre les
intérêts particuliers
la guerre de tous contre tous contre le
rassemblement le nécessaire
rassemblement pour l'intérêt général
la république indivisible et social
c'est ce rassemblement là que je veux
porter parce que je pense qu'il n'y a
que ça qui puisse
nous tirer du péril dans lequel notre
peuple est enfoncée désormais égal parce
que d'abord je suis un candidat hors
parti alors je ne sais pas si ça fait de
moi un meilleur candidat ou un moins bon
candidat chacun jugera
ça fait de moi un citoyen de la
république qui parle à tous mes
concitoyens mais égaux je veux comme
député pouvoir rassembler tous mes
concitoyens non seulement dans la 11e
circonscription
mais au delà dans la nation et je
voudrais que tous les députés puissent
faire de même pour poursuivre tout
simplement notre histoire commune celle
de notre nation sur le terrain je veux
être un député qui traque tous les
manquements des services publics qui
oeuvrent à une copie coopération
générale entre les associations
seule véritable alternative à
l'effondrement des institutions
c'est à dire de reconstruire la
république par le bas et à mon avis
c'est à cette condition et cette
condition seulement que la france
demeurera notre épopée
j'en suis convaincu